oh this is for kevin um when are we
gonna get our falcon bucky road trip
movie
wow yeah that's a good idea
okay so falcon in the winter soldier
episode 5 is probably the best entry in
the series so far
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down the story easter eggs
things you missed and giving our
theories on where the show could be
going for the finale next week
we're also going to be discussing
whether the big super duper hyped up
cameo was worth the speculation or not
our review of the show so far and behind
the scenes stuff over where things could
be going in the future
now episode 4 was called the whole world
is watching and huge shout outs to emma
louise on twitter for pointing out that
this is something that was chanted
during the trial of the chicago 7.
we followed sam bucky and zemo as they
tried to track down the flag smashers
and along the way they met up with the
new captain america and his best buddy
battlestar
bucky was given a deadline to hand zemo
over to the dora melange
so they could nail him but after he
palmed the deal off
they disarmed him hey now zemo was able
to escape
and the episode culminated with someone
who'd looked up to captain america his
entire life
looking up to him in his death now this
moment was very much a parallel to the
ending of civil war
in that cap smashed the shield down on
tony but rather than killing him he
decided to walk away
just deposing this jon let his anger get
the best of him
and this led to the shield being covered
in blood the legacy of captain america
was now tarnished
and episode 5 heavily tackles the
fallout and aftermath of this action
we're gonna be breaking it all down but
if you enjoy the video then please smash
the thumbs up button like john walker
smash that flag smasher
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this each and
every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the video
okay so episode 5 is called the truth
and it certainly brings a lot of light
to not only the super soldier serum
but america's actions as a whole jon
sees the truth of what he must become
and sam leans of what really happened to
isaiah bradley
making him wrestle over whether to
become kappa not
racking in at 61 minutes it's a longest
disney plus show episode that we've ever
had
in the beginning walker flees the scene
of the crime and he gets flashes of
hoskins
which i think calms him down lamar was
the one that was always keeping him down
to earth
and even in death the memory of him does
too his family later send walker off in
a certain direction
and it's clear that he very much holds
on to him as a guiding force
as we learned from erskine the super
soldier serum simply amplifies what's
within
so good becomes great and bad becomes
worse
the aforementioned civil war parallels
continue where we join sam and bucky who
show up at the location
this heavily mirrors the scene in that
movie when buggy sam and steve met in a
garage
hoping to snap the other out of the
hypnotic rage that he'd had induced
both scenes are somewhat dealing with a
public outburst by a super soldier
and on top of this i think the stance 2
mirrors the final battle of that movie
this is namely the way things are shot
and how it's pretty much a two-on-one
situation
involving bucky and captain america as
well as a normal person who uses
machines to give them enhanced abilities
the fight scene is awesome and the fact
that john is able to hold his own
against both of them
is a testament to how dangerous that he
is even before the super soldier serum
this guy had been awarded the medal of
honor three times and with the
enhancements on top he's pretty much
unstoppable george lucas pops up to say
it's like poetry they rhyme
because we end the fight with walker on
top of sam again
calling back to the final fight in civil
war in which cap bested tony
walker says i am captain america a line
he repeats throughout the episode
and he goes to do the shield slam once
more this shows he doesn't really regret
doing what he did to the flag smasher
and will continue to get worse and worse
if they don't stop him
the pair managed to beat him by breaking
his arm and sam takes the shield
using it for the first time to bring a
bad guy down bucky drops it for sam
and then walks off further calling back
to how steven he did it with tony
even the music cues are the same and it
brings everything full circle
from what is probably in my top three
favorite marvel movies
sam clearly realizes the
responsibilities that he now has
and knows that if he doesn't bear the
shield then someone else likely will
and they could be much worse taurus
returns and this character has been
pretty absent in the series so far
but in the comics he actually becomes
the falcon when sam becomes captain
america
thus him taking a shine to the wings and
sam saying keep him
does foreshadow his eventual arc back in
washington
walker is stripped of his title and
authority as captain america
due to his service to his country he's
not recommended for court martial
but his life in the army is clearly over
this is a man that gave
everything he could and the second he
made a mistake he was thrown out faster
than james charles at a high school
disco
he and his wife have a conversation that
very much mirrors the first one we saw
in episode two
but instead of being there for him as he
starts his career
she's now there after it's over not long
after they're approached by valentina
allegra defontaine
who you may know by her villain named
monika madame hydra
in the comics she's a pretty big
antagonist that started her career
working with shield
before moving on to bigger and badder
things i'm guessing that
in the mcu it will be revealed that she
was part of shield
and then when hydra rose up they sunk
their claws into her
though this wasn't one of the big names
that a lot of people were theorizing i
think that comic fans
will go crazy over it as she's such a
cool character in the source material
this definitely shines across with her
personality and though
i know a lot of you wanted people like
wolverine i thought it was going to be
goalie horn
so it looks like we're out here taking
more l's than shane dawson
she definitely has a big personality and
the actress julia louise dreyfuss is
someone that you may recognize from
seinfeld
arrested development and kirby
enthusiasm
according to the black widow wiki she's
in that film too
so expect to see her again at some point
in the mcu
another interesting thing is that a
business card has nothing on it
further hinting to how hidden away hydra
is at this point
the last time we saw them was in ant-man
when they stole crosses pin particles
so they are definitely out there and
ready to make a comeback now the comic
version of john walker has some
similarities to what we've seen in the
show so far
but also some big deviations that i'm
going to be discussing
jonathan walker to give him his full
name was born in custer's grove georgia
where he grew up idolizing his older
brother mike because of his service in
the army
at this young age john only saw the good
in war and because of heroes like
captain america
he didn't really consider the downsides
however it was surreal that mike
suffered from ptsd
and one night he burned the house down
by accident which racked him with guilt
mike took his own life not long after
but john's parents lied to him
and told him that he died in combat jon
wanted to live up to his brother's
memory
and from here he enlisted sadly because
of his brother being put on a pedestal
in his own mind
john didn't believe that he lived up to
his memory and thus he ended up
undergoing the power broker process
which gave him super strength
walker became super patriot which is
something that's been skipped over in
the show
and under this moniker he publicly
discredited captain america
he staged attacks and was genuinely a
bad dude
that wanted to terrorize the public into
believing that cap wasn't doing a good
job
however things changed and after cat put
down the shield
walker picked it up and became a more
violent and vengeful captain america
alongside battle star he brutally beat
people up and badly burned the
character's left winger and right winger
showing that he was far more aggressive
than steve ever was
now an important thing in this arc is
that it was actually the death of his
parents that sent him off the deep end
and not battle star eventually steve
ended up coming back as a character
called captain
he took back the shield and walker's
death was faked he re-emerged as us
agent in a black and red variation on
the costume
and has pretty much become an anti-hero
in the comics now whether intentional or
not
huge shout outs to beyond epic who
pointed out that walker's uniform was
missing the white that we typically saw
with steve's
this is normally a color of innocence
hinting to us this entire time that he's
not a good guy now the episode ends with
him creating his own shield
likely symbolizing that he's gonna
become us agent i'm guessing at some
point down the line he will work with
madame hydra
and potentially they could even fake his
death in the show
but that remains to be seen it's very
interesting and does line up with
certain things
but obviously let me know your thoughts
below the flag smashes return to the
refugee camp they were hiding out at
and find that the place has been cleared
out by the grc
a flyer states that they had accused
them of harboring terrorists
which carly takes personally even though
it is kind of the truth at this point
much like walker
she sees herself as being beyond and
above the law and rather than
seeing how her actions simply lead to
more loss she decides to enact her plan
as predicted zemo escaped and fled to
the sokovian memorial
a location he mentioned at the end of
episode 3. i love how chilling this
scene is between him and bucky
and it's clear that zemo tries to impart
his beliefs into him
his mission the entire time has been to
wipe out the super soldiers from the
face of the earth
and though many suspect that he may be
involved with the power broker
i think because of this he's definitely
not zemo believes that because of
bucky's past that he will always resort
to killing
and makes him think that it's the right
path to take in order to handle kali
however bucky shows he won't even kill
zemo
and instead hands him over to the dora
melange highlighting that he is truly no
longer the killer that he was made to be
zemo is taken to the raft which we know
from civil war
is overseen by general ross in the
comics ross actually recruits zemo to
join his group of anti-heroes the
thunderbolts
and thus them selecting this location
sets the team up
sam returns to isaiah bradley and we see
his grandson eli again
who becomes a young adventurer in the
comic books known as patriot
bradley may have passed his abilities
onto him genetically and thus it could
set up his appearance in the young
avengers
isaiah and sam talk about the history of
the shield with one another
and if you check out our video on
episode 2 you'll know how we discuss
that his creation was a metaphor for the
tuskegee syphilis study
this took place between the 1930s up
until the 1970s
and it centered around the us government
wanting to study the long-term effects
of the disease
thus they pretended to treat black
people but they simply injected them
with placebos
and allowed them to slowly die all
whilst letting them believe that they
were cured
isaiah actually mentions the 332 which
could be a reference to the 332nd
fighter group
which is a name that belonged to the
tuskegee airmen a group of black fighter
pilots now i know that there's a number
of people out there that will be annoyed
at how
quote unquote woke this stuff is but if
you look back on the history of captain
america
he's always been someone that's
discussed controversial topics
hell even the famous cover of him
punching hitler was released before
america joined the war
and even back then a lot of people were
angered by it captain america
is not an apolitical character and off
the top of my head i can't actually
think of anyone in the comics
that's more based in politics than he is
the legacy he left has clearly destroyed
several lives
including isaiah who was jailed and kept
from speaking to his wife
who died while steve was in prison we
discovered that he and his unit were
injected with what he believed was a
tetanus shot
and this lines up a lot with the comics
in those it was actually
nagel that did this and though we know
from the timeline that this wasn't the
case in the show
it does make sense to have these
characters coming back to tell this
story
isaiah saved his squadron similar to
what steve did in the first avenger
but whereas he came home as a hero
isaiah was experimented on for three
decades
it's a heartbreaking and harrowing tale
that discusses why we've
only heard about isaiah now as he was
declared dead
he discusses the eurasia of black
history over the last 500 years
and states that no self-respecting black
man would ever be captain america
because of this
this is the talking point that is often
been brought up with black soldiers
most famously muhammad ali who refused
to fight in vietnam because
he didn't want to put his life on the
line for a country that didn't view him
as an equal citizen
sam would very much become a tool rather
than simply being a person
and if they were willing to cast out
walker after he served his use
you can bet that the same thing would
happen with him it's a tough
conversation for sam to hear
and he returns home to his sister and
nephews the show really scales back
and focuses on him fixing his family
boat which sort of acts for a metaphor
for him fixing his mentality
bucky aka mr stelio's sister arrives
with a package from wakanda in a
suitcase
which is a similar aesthetic to the one
that tony had in iron man 2
and the one that the tesseract was
carried in the pair picks up the boat
and sam reluctantly lets bucky stay the
night
just a word of warning though yeah be
careful with your sister mate
now these quote-unquote fixing scenes
tend to only happen in iron man movies
but whenever they're used they're very
much put in place to strengthen a
character and symbolize them rebuilding
i very much get this idea from these
moments and it's all building towards
some opening up that case
elsewhere walker visits battle star's
parents and a huge shout out to wyatt
russell for completely
knocking out the park throughout this
episode whereas the government have
shunned walker because he avenged his
friend
it's clear that others including hoskins
family appreciate that he was
willing to step over the line to get
what they see as justice
it further hammers home in his mind that
he is the hero that the world deserves
and though he's not the one it needs
he's willing to still be there
setting him off on a path to become a
different kind of hero
ego's son hey gets an ego and he will be
returning which i am excited to see
now we jump to sharon carter on the
phone and shouts to all my people who
watch these shows with closed captions
on
as through this we discover it's batroc
on the other end
she says that she can pay him double
this time seemingly confirming that she
was the one who gave him the money to
kidnap the u.s soldier in episode one
it does seem to set up that she is the
power broker but i
am still in two minds about this as zemo
did state he knew him before civil war
which if we go back to was when sharon
was agent 13.
she also let nagel die and was willing
to kill her own men
which doesn't make sense if she is
indeed the villain
therefore i believe that she's actually
just working for the power broker
and that she has her own plans from the
trailers we know that sharon is involved
in the attack on the grc next week
but how it pans out is going to be
interesting to see
sam starts to train with the shield and
he says it feels weird which is a
callback to the end of end game
the pair discussed the symbolism of a
black man being handed the shield
and you might even remember that it was
controversial among some fans after the
end of end game
as always there was the get welcome
broke commentary by people
who completely overlooked that it
happened in the comics and i appreciate
that they have this sort of meta
commentary here
sam gives bucky some tough love and
though mr nakajima isn't mentioned
he's clearly hindered out because of the
closure comment bucky of course killed
his son
and he doesn't know what happened but he
decides to get people to forgive him
so he can forgive himself sam realizes
that he and his people have fought for
so much
and like the boat he refuses to let it
go and thus decides to become
captain america he picks the shield up
similar to what he did at the start of
episode 1
but this time instead of handing it over
he starts training
much like how he saw walker doing in his
propaganda video
we're gonna need a montage and sam
slowly gets adept
at using the shield elsewhere batroc
meets with the flag smashes
and he has a package for them again the
power broker has been hunting for them
this entire series
and thus i think that if it was sharon
that she would simply have him take them
out
if she was behind it all however it does
seem like she wants batroc to kill a
falcon
showing that she can't be trusted he
supplies them with weapons
and carly calls together the people's
army of the flag smashers
to launch their attack in new york they
plan to destroy the grc during the
patchak vote
and through torres we discovered that
because they didn't use a vpn
that sam now knows they're in new york
anyone else think this would have been
the perfect video to have a vpn
sponsorship in or or is it just me
well it isn't just me as now it's the
perfect time to tell you
uh this video is i'm just kidding now
some of it's the case
likely seeing his white captain america
uniform which
was used in the comics go to the post
credits scene and we see walker building
his own shield
in the episode five and six trailer we
actually got a look at this
and though we theorized it might be the
original one from endgame
he's made it from the ground up this
welding and hammering scene is very
similar to the one at the start of iron
man
and hey if tony can have a path of
redemption through this then
there's no reason that walker can't
either i love this moment
and seeing him put his medal of honor
into the shield itself
shows that he's now ready to bring forth
a new kind of hero
i think that next week he and sam will
actually team up with one another
as sam of course dealt with vets before
becoming steve's friend
and if anyone can help walker then it's
gonna be him
either way it was a great episode and i
can't wait to see what happens next time
now as for the episode itself i have to
say that this
in my opinion is the best one and
according to the series writer
it's also the one he's most proud of we
may have peaked before the finale next
week
but either way i thought this was a
really enjoyable entry
now as for the season as a whole i think
this kind of highlights
some of the issues that i have with it
on tuesday i did a big live stream with
josh from den of the nerds
in which we discussed some of the cut
plot lines from the show
and our general thoughts on it now one
of the big things that came up was that
we find walker a far more interesting
character
than carly is on paper i can't see
exactly why they chose her as a somewhat
antagonist
anti-hero as she's very much an opposite
to the us military
you have this young meek and almost very
shy girl
which is completely the other end of the
spectrum to the might and entire murder
that are hunting her down
it's very much the people versus the
institution and i can't see how
when they were scripting this that they
decided this is what the character
should represent
however i just don't find her that
charismatic and because of this
it's difficult for me to see why people
might decide to follow her
she just doesn't feel like a leader to
me and this may be because we know that
several plot lines were cut from the
show because of the pandemic
apparently there was a big virus plot
which is why we had a bit about the flag
smashes stealing vaccines
and also mamadonia dying from a disease
according to the leaks this wasn't
actually tb
and the character had a far more fleshed
out role which is meant to make us feel
the impact of her death a lot more
i think on re-watches you can kind of
tell but i do want to say that i still
think marvel have done a great job of
crafting a coherent storyline
even with a big arc missing from it
although i constantly sound like i'm
crapping on the show whenever i do these
review bits i do still really really
like it
and i feel like it's flying high as a
flagship title on disney plus
that lets us know these shows are gonna
have a high level of quality
and acting within them i think that the
more i've seen of wyatt russell
the more i realized how good his
performance is and though i can't really
co-sign the character's actions
sometimes
i think that's the sign of his acting
elevating the role to someone we've
grown to love to hate
this was an episode that added even more
to that and i think it's at the point
now where he's gonna be the most
memorable thing about it when we look
back on the show in several years
anthony mackie and sebastian stanler of
course great too
i don't want to sound ungrateful as this
is a really really good show
that feels mature in its handling of
certain topics and talking points
again another great episode in the
series and i do like it yeah i i do i
promise now going forward
we have a lot to talk about in regards
to the future of the marvel universe
firstly there are some cool little
things to talk about from an interview
with wyatt russell with the bbc
that does sort of tease what could be
happening next time
have you ever actually met chris evans
because if you were ever side by side in
the photo that would break the internet
right now
would it for sure i have ever met
chris evans i think i have i think i i
don't think i've like
shook his hand met him but i think i've
walked by him
somewhere and like made eye contact
because that and
that doesn't count as bad that counts as
like being a stalker
that doesn't count as meeting anybody
but um i
i guess yeah i guess it would you just
gotta wait till the end of the series
and then everybody will be like oh
my god love it hate it i don't know
they'll react that's for sure now
because of this the internet is
suspecting that chris evans is going to
feature at the end of the series
and that he might even end up coming
face to face with walker
i'm not really sure on this is why it
does say he's not really interacted with
them that much
which i think he would have if they were
on set together a big question
still remains over what exactly has
happened to cap since the ending of
end game and many of us want to know
whether he's going to feature in the
series or not
i think it would be great if he was but
as always don't get your hopes up yeah
don't or i'll kick off now the set of
spider-man noah home has shown that the
shield is gonna become
a big prop in the mcu going forward as
there was a bus stop sign posted that
had the statue of liberty holding it up
the advert says meet nyc's newest and
tallest avenger
with a hashtag ny liberty avenger on the
bottom of it
now charles murphy has reported that the
location will feature in the backdrop of
a key scene
and i'm guessing that they'll cgi the
shield onto the statue
and that it could be a big set piece or
even just something to show that new
york has rallied together
maybe after the events of the series
we'll see how the shield truly becomes a
symbol of good once more
and this brings the world back together
i'd love to see that and
after all our heroes have been through
they do deserve some time of people just
saying
yeah you are good people we don't hate
you
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode our review
and what you think will happen in the
finale as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize through on the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown over whether
we think
john walker and io were right which will
be linked on screen right now
we've discussed some of the most
controversial talking points from the
last episode
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sticking through the video
i've been poor let's see you next time
take care peace